[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mercredi à 6
juin 56 spectacle est autant de
découvertes pour sa nouvelle saison de
théâtre de 50 ans du gène vous emmène en
voyage
nous ferons le point sur la
programmation dans un lycée de banlieue
une répétition tourner la prise d'otages
la ferme de bel ébat avec les marques du
5 juin
la pièce taisez vous ou je tire sur
celle des lycéens saint quentinois et à
versailles le mois de juin rime avec
théâtre la cité royale
et cette année encore au coeur du mois
molière plus de 350 représentations sont
proposés le mois de juin rime aussi avec
présentation de saison et pour commencer
ce tour des salles de spectacles
saint-quentinoise nous partons au
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
camille lambert pour les moyens
techniques partir loin très loin ou tout
près de chez soi pour sa saison 2018
2019 le théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines programme
l'art comme outil de partage et de
découverte 55 spectacles sont à voir à
me faire le point
eh oui
[Applaudissements]
et
marie dj bonjour bonjour vous êtes la
directrice adjointe du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
alors cette saison qu'est ce que ça nous
réserve des voyages des femmes à des
voyages des femmes à travers ça on peut
dire pour simplifier une très grande
ouverture aux autres et une très grande
ouverture au monde en restant près de
chez soi c'est le plaisir du spectateur
que de voyager tout en restant ainsi
comment est ce qu'elle est pensée
cette saison il ya un thème un fil rouge
et pas de fil rouge mais il ya le souci
de créer des équilibres déséquilibre
entre ce qui vient de loin et
ce qui vient d'ici déséquilibre entre ce
qui relève de la culture classique
beaucoup de gens font leurs premiers pas
de spectateurs en venant découvrir des
grands auteurs classiques des grands
textes classiques du répertoire de
théâtre d'autres sont plus curieux
souhaitent découvrir des voix venues du
monde où des formes théâtrales qui
requiert de nouvelles technologies ou
qu'ils inventent des dramaturgies un
petit peu différente de celle qu'on a
l'habitude de voir
donc nous on travaille avec le désir et
l' envie de donner à voir des palettes
les plus larges possibles
il ya effectivement pas mal de femmes
dans cette
c'est au 2018 2019 soit en tant que
créatrice parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
fermes dans le monde artistique qui sont
des créatrices de talent d'un teresa de
keersmaeker grande chorégraphe
européenne mariann monteiro freitas
jeune chorégraphe cap verdienne on a
aussi beaucoup de voix de femmes
qui traverse toute la saison il ya du
jazz il ya de la musique africaine vous
fait voyager
il ya aussi un spectacle
particulièrement qui est le disent les
10 et 11 octobre
c'est d'ailleurs de l'autre voulait
qu'un voyage très très loin on voyage
très loin oui alors en voyage à travers
les techniques vocales puisque les
quatre chanteuses
ce spectacle appartiennent à l'ensemble
vocal les cris de paris dirigé par
geoffroy jourdain et geoffroy jourdain
et à quelques années a mis la main sur
des échantillons sonores venus du monde
entier notamment des chants des chants
de femmes des perceuses des appels au
recueillement
des appels à la à la chasse validé que
c'est oui à quelque chose de magique et
d'assez spirituel dans tous ces chants
qui l'a accueilli en a fait un spectacle
avec l'aide de d'aliénor douchez qui est
une pareille jeunes femmes metteurs en
scène très prometteuse est très
intéressante et là on est vraiment dans
des voix lyrique qui essayent de
s'emparer d'un répertoire qui n'est pas
du tout le leur avec pas de partition
des techniques vocales qui sont
radicalement différentes
donc il faut se réinventer
[Rires]
non
[Musique]
et
des kings dean quelque 10 km
voilà donc le lier de l'autre c'est ça
disent ça dit bien ce que c'est
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs lointain de
l'autre qui n'est pas moi vous le disiez
vous avez cité en tant que femme anne
teresa de keersmaeker nous avait aussi
une grosse page d'ansouis intéressante
car souika un monde de la danse elle est
incontournable incontournable dans le
monde de la danse elle est
incontournable dans un parcours de
spectateurs qu'ils soient novices ou
amateurs éclairés de danse c'est
vraiment une grande figure de la de la
danse européenne qui présentera tout un
répertoire dans toute l'île de france
durant tout l'automne avec le festival
d'automne à paris dont nous sommes cette
année encore les partenaires autre
chorégraphe alors là c'est quand on a
beaucoup parlé dans la capitale benjamin
millepied il était directeur de la danse
de l'opéra il est reparti hoel et james
project et evian novembre chez vous oui
tous taxés alors il avait créé le elle
est dense project il ya quelques années
déjà avant même de venir prendre la
direction de la danse à l'opéra de paris
c'est une compagnie qui l'a créée pour
rassembler des créateurs de diverses
disciplines et il s'attache à il
présente évidemment ses propres
chorégraphies mais aussi quelque chose
qui relève du répertoire de la danse y
aura notamment pendant cette soirée qui
sera vraiment une soirée exceptionnelle
re découverte de pièces de martha graham
qu'elle chorégraphe post moderne
américaine qui a s'est peu montré sur
les scènes françaises et qui s'attache
lui à mettre en valeur au milieu d'un
répertoire très complet c'est dans ces
créations notamment n'ont jamais une
pierre non pas très américain il a tout
fait il s'est formé là bas c'est
désormais la plus loin que l'école
française tout à fait il a dansé aussi
sous la direction du chorégraphe
américain il est vraiment empreint de
cette double culture et c'est
globalement ce qu'on a envie de montrer
nos six lors de cette prochaine saison
c'est comment toutes les cultures
peuvent cohabiter et fabriquer des
objets artistiques singuliers
on est dans un territoire qui est très
ouvert à l'international avec des
événements aussi internationaux la ryder
cup
prochainement les jeux olympiques
beaucoup d'entreprises qui travaillent à
l'échelle mondialisée donc ce qu'on peut
montrer aussi à travers les langages
artistiques c'est que le monde il est à
portée de main mais qu'en même temps il
peut nous offrir des singularités de
deux points de vue des singularité
esthétique des singularités de langage
il ya un spectacle aussi à noter
peut-être du 14 au 16 décembre
il n'est pas encore minuit la
particularité c'est vingt deux acrobates
oui sur votre self est aussi une scène
qui permet de recevoir les grandes
prestations c'est une scène qui permet
de recevoir de grandes prestations pour
un large public et là on est typiquement
dans
un spectacle qui est vraiment écrit pour
de grandes audiences effectivement une
vingtaine d'artistes sur scène dans un
geste acrobatique très impressionnant
des tours humaines très spectaculaire
donc on est dans du cirque évidemment
puisque c'est le cirque c'est l'art de
la prouesse est que là on est
complètement dans cet art de la prouesse
on est aussi dans une adresse très très
large point public très familial
al'approche des fêtes de noël
on
[Applaudissements]
manqué
mais
[Musique]
faux dit un peu plus tôt il ya du
clasico si vous souhaitez a amené de
nouveaux publics
oui avec notamment des grands acteurs
patrick timsit aussi populaire on va
deuxième toute assez l'une des missions
du théâtre oui c'est une des missions du
théâtre
c'est l'une des missions du théâtre que
de faire découvrir ou redécouvrir des
classiques avec un angle d'aujourd'hui
alors timsit patrick timsit tout le
monde le connaît peut-être comme
humoriste ou comme comédien au cinéma
c'est vrai que c'est un très grand
acteur de théâtre extrêmement subtile le
livre de ma mère d'albert cohen raconte
l'amour d'un fils pour sa mère et si tu
avais envie depuis trente ans quand même
de monter cette oeuvre littéraire
il a rencontré dominique pitoiset que
les spectateurs de saint quentin en
yvelines connaissent bien qui est venu à
plusieurs reprises notamment avec cyrano
de bergerac café tabac d'entendre le
monde entier donc là ils se sont trouvés
pour mettre en scène cette oeuvre
littéraire
donc c'est une façon à la fois d'être
avec un grand acteur populaire de
découvrir un texte que beaucoup
connaissent mais peut-être peu de gens
ont lu véritablement sous la houlette
d'un metteur en scène qui est rompue
finalement à cet exercice de créer pour
des grandes salles et de larges
audiences en est au théâtre maintenant
il ya un rendez vous annuel
les rencontres in situ oui la troisième
mission installer oui ça va donner de
l'appétit
exactement c'est chaque saison une
thématique différente le temps puis
demain humain de bain interrogations et
en 2019 donc en mars 2010neuf pendant
toute une semaine
la question de l'alimentation comment
est-ce que pourquoi est ce qu'on mange
qu'est ce qu'on mange et aussi pourquoi
est-ce qu'on se met à table
pourquoi chez nous c'est un moment clé
il ya exactement et pourquoi on se met à
table et qu'on mange pas assis comme
dans certaines cultures
d'où viennent certaines habitudes
alimentaires qu'est ce qu'on trouve dans
nos aliments
voilà une approche anthropologique
sociologique culinaire ludique
gustatives aussi un puisqu'on va voir
certains spectacles au cours desquelles
on pourra sentir ressentir boire manger
et vraiment mettre en éveil tous les
sens que nous avons
merci marie d'idées et pour découvrir
toute la prochaine saison du théâtre
direction le site internet qui s'affiche
en bas de l'écran
la saison 2017-2018 continue au théâtre
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines les 8 et 9
juin prochains
ce sont les aventures du baron de
münchausen qui vous attendent des
aventures revisité en ou perrin pouces
ils sont passés de l'atelier à la scène
27 lycéens lui on courtois et illimitées
ont joué à la ferme de bel ébat de
guyancourt ils ont présenté et taisez
vous ou je tire une pièce de médecine
hommage aux inspiré de la journée de la
jupe un travail d'une année présenté
mardi 5 juin
regardez
[Musique]
un lycée de banlieue une professeure son
autorité et une arme introduites les
apprentis comédiens sont des lycéens
saint quentinois il ajouté et vous ou je
tire une création de métier nava jo
j'aimais bien que ça parle de nous dans
un des lycéens on est les premiers
touchés parce qu'on est des élèves on
est sensible à tout ça au début la pièce
qu'on semblait très compliquée et
j'avais du mal à j'avais du mal et faire
ce que ça a changé beaucoup de ce qu'on
avait vu dans les deux précédents
projets et me fur et à mesure on a
appris à travailler ils sont une
trentaine à avoir répété toute l'année
en dehors de l'entente scolaire un
travail hebdomadaire pour les lycées
villa rois et des cartes
encadrés par la troupe professionnelle
d'albert groupe lacasse effort sépare et
parlent de leur situation et leurs
préoccupations puisque ça se passe dans
un lycée il ya des difficultés avec une
preuve et ses astra et puis d'autre part
le fait de jouer avec du lard ou aussi
ça leur a apporté beaucoup de choses
[Musique]
c'est essentiel on ne peut pas porter
les mêmes choses
en tant que professeur et en tant que
metteur en scène en tant qu aux médias
donc chacun apporte sa pierre et c'est
ensemble qu'on construit quelque chose
et quand on est des professeurs
différents dans des lycées différents on
apporte aussi un regard différent sur
les élèves un travail conclu par une
date unique à la ferme de bel ébat de
guyancourt avant pour certains de
réfléchir à la prochaine création
[Musique]
au mois de juin la ville de versailles
devient un théâtre à ciel ouvert du 1er
au 30 juin
c'est la 23ème édition du mois molière
70 lieux plus de 350 représentations des
créations françois de mazières vous êtes
le maire de la commune et le créateur de
ce rendez vous culturel qu'est ce que
vous nous avez concocté cette année un
beaucoup de choses c'est impossible à
résumer un vous cia qui a 350
représentations il ya 63 lieux de
spectacles donc cesser il faut se
plonger dans le programme et trouver son
bonheur
mais disons soul et le principe du moyen
a toujours été le même depuis 23 ans que
c'est la 23ème édition cette année
c'est du théâtre qui sauvera sotomo
notamment aux familles mais c'est aussi
de la musique un petit hack est un peu
de danse comme chaque année du côté du
théâtre il ya des reprises mais aussi
des créations 12 cette année vous aimez
la privilégier cette création
ah oui pour nous ce qu'est c'est très
important si vous voulez d'avoir un
festival qui met en avant notamment les
jeunes troupes les troupes qui à nos
yeux à mes yeux puisque c'est moi quand
nationale la programmation ont un vrai
potentiel et c'est peut-être
l'originalité ce festival parmi d'autres
c'est que vous avez vraiment ici une
sorte de de terreau vivant de ce qu'est
la jeune création française en matière
de cartes
évidemment ce n'est pas à avignon
avignon en citant un festival
gigantesque extraordinaire c'est le plus
gros du monde mais on est là avant
festival in you pour permettre justement
un des troupes de prendre leur envol
ce sont tous des troupes d'excellent
niveau parce qu on les sélectionne avec
beaucoup de soin alors parmi les
créations il y as andromaque c'est celle
qui fait l'ouverture d'ailleurs du jean
racine mis en scène par anne delbée
alors ça c'est un spectacle c'est une
création une création non pas bien sûr
la pièce parce que là il faut remonter à
16 ans je crois 67 767 quand j'estime
créé avec la troupe du théâtre de
bourgogne
cette pièce qui est une des très grandes
pièces de racine et mais c'est une
création de mise en scène par une grande
dame du théâtre qui s'appelle anne
delbée un delbé dans le cadre français
très connu pour justement être la
tragédienne
sa passion c'est la tragédie est la
montée d'ailleurs ce qu'on appelait la
trilogie de racine et 3 très grande
pièce de racine à la montée c'est
d'abord un fait qui avait marqué la
commune française
et puis ensuite au festival d'avignon où
justement est donc un élever sa patience
et la tragique et on lui a demandé si
elle voulait bien remonter en 2010 sa
pièce fétiche vrai dire et puis on
parlait elle va monter aussi le
misanthrope de molière est doublement
confiant fans d'aller oui parce que ce
qui est intéressant dans le projet sous
lé sait que anne delbée souligné que ces
deux pièces ont été écrits quasiment au
même moment puisque molière créer les
misanthropes ans et 166
vous avez donc 567 la création
d'andromaque par racine et au fond les
deux l'ont fait pour la même actrice et
qui s'appelait manuel du parent qui tait
son nom de théâtre ont fait un principe
du mois molière c'est aussi la ville de
versailles qui est un théâtre à ciel
ouvert des lieux emblématiques des
grandes écuries l'espace riche que nous
sommes
marché notre dame voulait vive faire
vivre la ville et le théâtre pendant un
mois ah oui la caractéristique du mois
molière c'est que maman il va dans tous
les cas tu es vous savez moi j'ai un
petit peu une obsession dans la
programmation c'est d'essayer de dire
qu'on peut offrir des spectacles de
qualité à tout le monde et il ya souvent
la barrière de l'argent donc on évite la
barrière de l'engeance que de nombreux
spectacles sont gratuits
merci françois de mazières alors le mois
molière a débuté le vendredi 1er juin il
se déroule à versailles jusqu'au 30 juin
pour le coup de coeur cinéma de la
semaine nous partons aux yeux d'elsa
saint cyr l'école on écoute bertrand
pinet et bien le coup de coeur du cinéma
les yeux d'elsa
cette semaine c'est la continuation du
festival les yeux pleins d'étoilés notre
septième édition sur le thème de la
science fiction est particulièrement
vendredi soir vendredi 8 juin à partir
de 20h15 nous diffuserons 3 film
d'animation d'animation japonaise
traditionnellement tous les ans on
organise une soirée animations et
cette année c'est donc le 8 juin avec
mutafukaz un film réalisé par un
japonais et un français le français
s'appelant guillaume renard le deuxième
film c'est perfect blue un film
absolument gigantesque un thriller
psychologique formidable réalisé par
satoshi kon et akira un film majeur dans
l'histoire du cinéma d'animation
japonais réalisé par katsuhiro otomo
[Musique]
nous vous en parlions la semaine
dernière le samedi 2 juin c'était la
septième édition du festival du court
métrage aux clayes-sous-bois 18 films
étaient en compétition l espace philippe
noiret retour sur cette édition avec des
images de michael ami de rohff un
premier prix pour une réflexion sur la
paternité une autoproduction de 14
minutes
le jury du festival a récompensé pripyat
le film de olivier cavellat c'est son
premier prix voilà j'enchaîne quelques
festivals et là c'est son premier prénom
très content j'ai eu un fils qui
s'appelle oui il ya six ans aujourd'hui
ben aujourd'hui à quelques quelques mois
est en fait moi contrairement à fabien
moi je me suis posé des questions avant
de faire un enfant et samaa j'ai mis un
certain temps à trouver des réponses
savoir ce que je voulais un enfant ou
pas voilà et le film part de la part de
cette interrogation face à lui 17 autres
films étaient en compétition des
réalisations de moins de 16 minutes pour
cette 7e édition du festival trois
heures de projection avant de longs
débats on se base principalement sur les
critères la qualité de l'image à qu'elle
était technique la qualité du scénario
la qualité de jeu
effectivement on essaie de trouver un
film qui puisse rassembler en fait tous
ces différents points et bien sûr qu'ils
puissent véhicules et de l'émotion c'est
très varié très éclectique comme
d'habitude et voilà on a de très belles
surprises il y avait pas mal de courts
métrages interdit aux moins de dix ou
douze ans donc c'est probablement voilà
un petit peu moins
un peu moins censure et autocensure et
en tout cas donc on a vraiment laissé
libre cours à la création et on sait
absolument pas interdit quoi que ce soit
en tout cas si entrepris ont été remis
lors de cette journée celui du public a
récompensé pourquoi lui de khamis un
gars ou joe dassin nous a quittés il ya
presque 40 ans mais nous connaissons
tous au moins un de ces titres le 21
juin prochain un gala solidaire va lui
rendre hommage à rambouillet sur scène
l'un de ses auteurs vivien vallée on
l'écouté vivien l'année bonjour bonjour
alors le 21 juin vous allez faire
revivre joe dassin calvo nord
quel bonheur les chutes et son copain
j'étais un de ses compositeurs
j'ai eu la chance de travailler avec lui
de faire des choix des chansons avec lui
et là on bénéficie d'une salle
magnifique à la lanterne de rambouillet
c'est une salle somptueuse
j'ai la chance d'être accompagné par la
troupe frenchkiss j'ai des chanteuses
qui sont avec moi nous avons créé un
groupe qui s'appelle le groupe couleur
champagne
et la soirée va être joyeuse il va y
avoir d'émotions il va y avoir des
savates un mélange d'amitié un petit peu
comme faisaient les carpentier jaune est
bien s'entourer d'amis
voilà c'est dans cet esprit-là tchad
afin qu'ils étaient pieds nous l'avait
bien connu
vous avez notamment écrit et les yeux
d'émilie oui c'était un échange si vous
pouviez vous proposer en fait la chanson
n'était pas pour lui du tout elle était
pour gérard lenorman et le protecteur de
jacques pellet a entendu cette chanson à
venger l'un de nos ventes et l'a fait il
a plu à chaud et joe
voilà a fait cette chanson la merveille
joe dassin ses objectifs qui restent
encore oui il a longtemps pris sa
disparition mais parce que ce sont des
chansons de la fusion les chansons très
très bien ficelé avec une mélodie qui se
retient et mélodies qui se développe qui
écrit des choses et qui est en symbiose
totale avec les paroles c'est c'est
vraiment vraiment du très très bon
le spectacle du 21 juin c'est une
création
oui total et vous l'avez dit vous serez
accompagné notamment de la troupe de
danse frenchkiss comment elle a été
pensée ce spectacle tout à fait dans
l'esprit des carpentier c'est à dire une
équipe de copains autour de jobs et des
choses les choses de la vie des choses
de l'amour avec des intervenants comme
ça mais ça cool c'est bien c'est sympa
assez bonne humeur c'est pas du tout
gain dé c'est la chaleur et puis on va
essayer avec la troupe frenchkiss de
mettre un petit peu d'élégance plus joe
était quelqu'un de très élégant et de
très simple on voit aussi de rester
dans cet esprit et fait aussi une
création abus de solidaires aux prises
avec le lion's club
les fonds seront donc reversés à des
actions humanitaires
oui oui un certain nombre d'actions
humanitaires
j'aurai à donner parce que franchement
avec les chansons réussir à créer une
causalité positive
c'était ce qui était jo jo était
quelqu'un de très positif et là c'est la
quadrature du cercle en fait en on est
heureux on fait des choses on voit le
public enchanté de belles chansons les
gens sont heureux dans plus on fait du
bien je crois qu'on est c'est le paradis
sur terre quoi et on va retrouver tous
les plus grands titres de joe dassin les
plus belles chansons un spectacle qui va
durer entre 1h20 1h30 et plus belles
chansons de joe vous avez connu combien
de temps elle crée ses spectacles ça
faisait un smoky ça un an certains noms
un an que nous travaillons dessus est
bon il faut bien que ça se termine parce
que là il faut une échéance
mais voilà oui il nous travaillons
beaucoup merci du jeu à l'aller merci à
vous alors le gala hommage aura lieu le
21 juin à la lanterne de rambouillet
qui sera le champion d'improvisation
2018 la finale du cycle mythe c'est le
12 juin prochain
cette année ça se joue entre les
collèges jules youri gagarine la mare au
sol la joue et les prêts début des
matchs à 20h30 à la mort de son père lui
la misère reçoit pour seul héritage un
chat mais un chat botté au théâtre
montansier vous pouvez redécouvrir le
conte de charles perrault l'adaptation
et signer la comédie nomadesk un extrait
de la bande annonce
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce site une culture
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
mercredi prochain
[Musique]